und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend das nachrichtengeschäft ist ein
unvorhersehbares mit überraschungen aus
london musste man heute rechnen da
passierte nichts die meldung des tages
betrifft syrien und kam am abend aus
berlin
die immer noch dort neue deutsche
verteidigungsministerin bricht eine
lanze für einen gemeinsamen europäischen
militäreinsatz in diesem dem derzeit
heißesten krisenherd weit und breit
deutsche sollen mit anderen europäern
dorthin wo die usa abziehen
andreas künast es ist ein abzug in
schimpf und schande
kartoffeln fliegen und beleidigungen als
sich diese us-truppen aus der kurdischen
stadt kamischli zurückziehen
ihre lügner die amerikaner seit lügner
läuft nur weg ihr raten wir werden alle
sterben
die wut auf die usa ist so groß wie die
enttäuschung über den rest der welt als
die mächtigen der europäischen union
vergangene woche auseinander gehen haben
sie eine erklärung beschlossen aber
keine taten die türkei hat freunde in
der eu wie den ungarn viktor orban die
eine bestrafung erdogans verhindern dass
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer nun einen deutschen
vorschlag aus der tasche zieht
abgestimmt mit kanzlerin merkel ist ein
paradigmenwechsel
bis gestern galt die eu bleibt zusammen
seit heute gilt deutschland geht voran
mein vorschlag ist dass wir eine
international kontrollierte
sicherheitszone einrichten unter
einbeziehung der türkei und unter
einbeziehung von russland mit andern
worten nach dem abzug der us-soldaten
sollen unter anderem europäische
soldaten für stabilität sorgen und den
kampf gegen denise weiterführen
wer als kurdische gemeinde deutschland
begrüßen diesen vorstoß unserer
bundesverteidigungsministerium
es wurde allerhöchste zeit dass
deutschland reagiert und europa reagiert
den außenminister hat kramp karrenbauer
heute per sms informiert obwohl sie
gestern im kanzleramt über syrien
sprachen die spd ist überrascht auch die
nato-verbündeten bekamen anrufer aus
berlin vor allem paris und london
es traf sich das airlines sprecher und
chefberater ibrahim calli in ohnehin im
kanzleramt war
wie diplomaten dem zdf bestätigen die
nato ist dabei aber die falsche adresse
wenn man so etwas diskutieren will dann
gehört das in den sicherheitsrat der
vereinten nationen
dort ist deutschland mitglied dort muss
es auf den tisch kramp-karrenbauer auch
deutsche soldaten nach syrien schicken
will
darüber sagt sie müsse der bundestag
entscheiden und damit der bundestag
entscheiden kann muss er wissen was die
regierung dort vorhat guten namen frau
ministerin haben sie schon eine
vorstellung
ich möchte dass wir nicht tatenlos
zuschauen wenn wir auf den nordirak
schauen dort haben wir zurzeit eine ganz
ganz schwierige humanitäre situation der
kampf gegen den es ist quasi eingestellt
das betrifft unsere
sicherheitsinteressen massiv und ich
schlage vor und wünsche mir dass wir
eine international kontrollierte
schutzzone dort einrichten um den kampf
gegen den esv setzen zu können aber auch
um wiederaufbau zu leistende mit
menschen in ihrer heimat wieder
zurückkehren können
sie meinen den das gebiet in nordsyrien
in dem die türkei nun einmarschiert ist
das hat ihr kollege außenminister
gestern erst als völkerrechtswidrig
erklärt wenn jetzt deutschland und
andere in der region mitmischen so dass
dadurch automatisch völkerrechts gemäss
wir haben eine ganz klare betrachtung
was das verhalten der türkei anbelangt
die frage ist ja was ist eine mögliche
alternative die alternative dass die
türkei auf dauer in dieser region bleibt
um ihre interessen zu wahren macht das
thema völkerrecht noch sehr viel
schwieriger wir haben in russland als
einen großen akteur in dieser region und
deswegen bin ich der auffassung wenn wir
möchten das sehr dass der terror weiter
bekämpft wird wenn wir möchten dass
menschen freiwillig wieder in diese
region zurückkehren können
dann müssen wir dort eine politische
lösung herbeiführen und deswegen
brauchen wir auch eine internationale
kontrolle und ein internationales
zusammenwirken und eben gerade nicht nur
das zusammenwirken zwischen russland und
der türkei
das heißt sie wollen mit russland und
der türkei sprechen wollen sie auch mit
syrien besprechung mit hamas ab
nein es geht zuerst einmal darum dass
wir aus europa heraus eine initiative
starten
die kanzlerin hat ja angekündigt dass
sie sich mit dem französischen
staatspräsidenten mit dem britischen
premierminister und auch mit dem
türkischen staatspräsidenten treffen
will
wir haben den deutsch-französischen
verteidigungs und sicherheitsrates
ich schlage vor dass wir den dazu
einladen die britischen kollegen und
dass wir von dort aus den vorschlag
machen wie eine solche international
kontrollierte zone aussehen kann dass es
zuerst einmal nur die fragestellung für
nordsyrien für nichts weiteres für
syrien selbst haben wir eine resolution
der vereinten nationen und die gilt wer
einen solchen vorstoß unternimmt und das
ist ja ziemlich erstmalig dass
deutschland ein militärisch dominierten
vorschlag unternimmt der kann sich nicht
auf dauer vornehm zurückhaltend wie die
deutschen bisher die in syrien in
tornados weit oben oder auf fregatten
weit draußen waren und nun reden sie
über einsatz am boden einem gebiet aus
dem die amerikaner raus gegangen sind
weil es ihnen zu heiß geworden
es geht zuerst einmal darum dass wir
natürlich auch mit militärischen mitteln
den kampf gegen den es weiterführen das
tun wir mit unseren fähigkeiten der
luftüberwachung aber auch der ausbildung
zur zeit im irak
es geht aber vor allen dingen auch darum
dass wir politische stabilität dort
schaffen und dass dort wieder aufgebaut
werden kann etwas was wir im irak auch
tun wie eine internationale mission und
ein darauf aufbauendes mandat im
bundestag aussehen müsste das ist eine
entscheidung die der bundestag zu
treffen hat die bundeswehr wird immer
das zur verfügung stellen was die
politik von ihr verlangt nun geht mir
ein bisschen unter die einmaligkeit
dieser situation deutschland hat noch
nie eingegriffen in einem militärischen
konflikt wo im moment scharf geschossen
wird
in einem heiß umkämpften gebiet und
übernimmt nun eine führungsrolle
wenigstens bei der vorbereitung dann
muss auch eine führungsrolle im
militärischen bereich folgen würde man
denken zuerst einmal geht es darum dass
wir auf der politischen und
diplomatischen ebene eine europäische
antwort geben können unter einbeziehung
natürlich auch der türkei und von
russland und in enger abstimmung mit dem
vereinigten staaten ich bin der meinung
das steht uns gut an zumal in einer
woche in denen sich europäische
verteidigungsminister mit ihrem kollegen
etwa aus den vereinigten staaten auch in
brüssel treffen werden
eine gute gelegenheit um das thema
anzusprechen zuerst einmal geht es um
die politische initiative um die
politische lösung was dazu militärisch
aber auch im zivilen aufbau erforderlich
ist dass es der zweite schritt und auch
da muss man dann darüber reden wie kann
der beitrag deutschlands aussehen aber
wir können nicht nur beklagen was in
dieser region passiert und als europa
keine antwort geben und wir sind einer
der stärksten partner in europa und
deswegen kommt es aus meiner sicht auch
auf uns an
nun sind sie aber bereit in diesem
ungewöhnlichen fall über das hinaus zu
gehen was deutsche soldaten in anderen
welt gebieten von afghanistan bis irak
bisher geleistet haben bei dieser
situation das erfordert zuerst einmal
was wir am ende des tages dort leisten
werden ist noch nicht entschieden
das ist entscheidungsgrundlage des
bundestages zum zweiten geht es vor
allen dingen darum dass wir eben auch
eine grundlage schaffen für einen
zivilen wiederaufbau denn wir müssen ja
sehen dass wir nicht nur eine massive
sicherheitsbedrohung haben durch die
freigelassenen ex kämpfer sondern dass
wir auch die situation haben dass sehr
viele menschen in dieser region auf der
flucht sind dass sie auch angrenzende
regionen destabilisieren das alles
betrifft die europäischen und auch die
deutschen interessen
und deswegen haben wir ein interesse
daran dass es eine politisch
dauerhaftere lösung für nordthüringen
gibt und wenn wir einen beitrag dazu
leisten können zuerst einmal politisch
und diplomatisch dann sollten wir das
tun
eine kleinigkeit noch zur koalition ist
es richtig dass sie den außenminister
von diesem vorstoß per sms
unterrichtet habe ich habe eben darüber
informiert dass sich als
verteidigungsministerin aber natürlich
auch als cdu vorsitzende die am
wochenende beklagt hat dass es zu wenig
politische antworten gibt auch aus der
eigenen partei einen vorschlag machen
werde
und insofern sind wir darüber im
austausch alles weitere muss natürlich
auch in der koalition besprochen werden
aber mir war es wichtig in dieser woche
in der so viele gespräche laufen in der
morgen auch der waffenstillstand der
vereinbarte ausläuft auch eine
initiative zu starten und damit auch
deutschland aber auch europa eine eine
stimme zu geben
sie haben also per sms informiert wir
sprachen per sms in kontakt
dankeschön und einen guten abend
bitteschön und dieses gespräch haben wir
genauso um 21 uhr geführt zu aktueller
innenpolitik die kanzlerin machte heute
dem deutschen gewerkschaftsbund ihre
aufwartung
mit anerkennenden worten in 70 jahren
bundesrepublik hätten die organisationen
der arbeitnehmer großen anteil am
wirtschaftlichen erfolg des landes weil
sie mit verantwortung übernahmen und
übernehmen mussten in tarif- und
sozialpolitik das freute die
versammelten funktionäre die im alltag
mächtig unter druck stehen die neue
wirklichkeit der arbeitswelt hat immer
weniger platz für traditionelle
organisationen die zahl der im dgb
organisierten arbeitnehmer hat sich fast
halbiert die macht der gewerkschaften
schwindet sie sind für viele in neu
ausgerichteten unternehmen nicht mehr
selbstverständlich die
interessenvertretungen der belegschaft
denn diese interessen wandeln sich
berichtet dominik löschmeister der
jugendclub des dgb in frankfurt hier
treffen sich junge
gewerkschaftsmitglieder in ihrer
freizeit die meisten machen gerade eine
ausbildung das thema arbeitszeit für die
berufsanfänger wichtiger denn je
auch die arbeitszeit das ist schon lange
thema dass das einfach verkürzt wird das
aus wirtschaftlichen aspekten gar nicht
mehr nötig ist dass die leute bis zu 40
stunden die woche arbeiten
heute wollen halt wo dieses
work-life-balance dinge auf jeden fall
haben also ich sehe schon dass es halt
nicht nur so ein trend ist sondern dass
es auch ist die arbeitszeit und die
verbesserung der bedingungen im betrieb
kernthemen des vor 70 jahren gegründeten
deutschen gewerkschaftsbundes
[Musik]
damit war der dgb 1956 für mehr freizeit
40 stunden und eine fünf tage woche das
ziel lohnfortzahlung im krankheitsfall
urlaubsgeld kündigungsschutz
ohne gewerkschaften wäre das wohl nie
durchgesetzt worden die stärke des dgb
das prinzip der einheitsgewerkschaft das
waren die lehren aus der weimarer
republik und der zerschlagung der
gewerkschaften am zweiten mai 1933 wo
die arbeiterbewegung gespalten war in
richtungs und konfessionellen
gewerkschaften und dass der deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund heute einheitlich
zusammensteht bedeutet beispielsweise
ein betrieb eine gewerkschaft einen
tarifvertrag das hat die gewerkschaften
stark gemacht
doch die arbeitswelt verändert sich der
heimathafen in wiesbaden ist eine
mischung aus café & co working das heißt
es gibt büroflächen zu mieten für
freiberufler ihre zahl wächst in
deutschland eine gewerkschaftliche
vertretung haben sie nicht
gewerkschaften können eine rolle spielen
haben sie brauchen aber auch die
empathie für die neue gruppe von
arbeitenden arbeitnehmer oder von
freiberuflern ich glaube diese empathie
so nicht da ist noch nicht da angekommen
den köpfen der freiberufler zu sagen wo
kann ich denn mich hinwenden wenn ich
fragen zur arbeit habt fragen zur
absicherung im alter
stark sind gewerkschaften dort wo es
noch große industriebetriebe gibt oder
im öffentlichen dienst hier können sie
noch viel durchsetzen
anderswo weigern sich die arbeitgeber
mit gewerkschaften überhaupt zu
verhandeln
deshalb wird eine aufgabe sein im
strukturwandel arbeitsbedingungen
entlohnungsbedingungen für alle menschen
zu gestalten und dafür brauche ich eine
deutlich höhere tarifbindung die zurzeit
noch mal bundesrepublikanischen
durchschnitt bei 55 57 prozent liegt das
ist viel zu wenig das zu ändern wird
auch die junge generation in dgb leisten
müssen antworten zu finden auf eine
veränderte arbeitswelt valerie diese
neue arbeitswirklichkeit wird den
aktuellen tarifverhandlungen der bau und
chemiegewerkschaft sehr praktisch es
geht nicht mehr in erster linie um
lohnerhöhungen
nein genau es geht eigentlich um mehr
selbstbestimmung für die beschäftigten
darum dass arbeitnehmer einfach die wahl
haben wollen zwischen mehr geld oder
mehr freizeit und eine antwort darauf
soll jetzt das persönliche zukunftskonto
seien beim zukunftskonto bekäme jeder
mitarbeiter jährlich 1000 euro dieses
geld kann dann in freie tage umgewandelt
oder auf ein langzeit konto angespart
werden
alternativ kann es auch ausgezahlt oder
für die altersvorsorge genutzt werden
die arbeitgebervertreter sind skeptisch
die chemiebranche steckt mitten im
abschwung die gewerkschaft kontert die
arbeitgeber sollten aus einem leichten
abschwung noch keine krise machen im
moment jedenfalls liegen beide seiten
mit ihren positionen noch weit
auseinander
und wie wird die industrie also die
arbeitgeber jetzt mit dieser neuen
herausforderungen umgehen also für die
arbeitgeber ist diese flexibilität der
beschäftigten natürlich schwierig vor
allem in zeiten von fachkräftemangel
dann müssen andere entweder mehr
arbeiten oder jemand neues muss
eingestellt werden beides kostet geld
ähnliche modelle haben übrigens schon
die eisenbahner und die metaller da gibt
es dann zum beispiel wieder mehr 40
stunden verträge für die die einfach
mehr arbeiten wollen oder es gibt
vetorechte für arbeitgeber aber egal in
welcher branche das ist schon ein sehr
hart umkämpftes thema dankeschön
und hier kommen die nachrichten der
britische premier johnson hat in seinen
tracks it bemühungen einen weiteren
rückschlag an den parlamentspräsident
bykow hat eine neue abstimmung über
johnsons jüngsten austritts vertrag
nicht zugelassen
die parlamentarier hätten schon am
samstag in der gleichen sache abgestimmt
nun sollen die abgeordneten von morgen
an über ein gesetzespaket zur umsetzung
von johnsons deal beraten
auch hier sind änderungsanträge zu
erwarten erst wenn london eingesetzt zur
ratifizierung verabschiedet hat will das
europaparlament über das vertragswerk
abstimmen
ein pünktlicher geordneter braig cit am
31 oktober wird offenbar wieder
unwahrscheinlicher nach den
massenprotesten im libanon hat die
regierung von ministerpräsident hariri
umfassende reformen angekündigt um gegen
misswirtschaft und korruption vorzugehen
so sollen die bezüge von abgeordneten um
die hälfte gekürzt werden auch neue
steuern werde es zunächst nicht geben
trotz der ankündigungen gingen in der
hauptstadt beirut erneut zahlreiche
demonstranten auf die straße und
forderten den rücktritt der regierung
der libanon kämpft seit längerem mit
einer wirtschafts und finanzkrise und
leidet zudem unter dem trägen
benachbarten syrien
israels premier netanjahu ist mit der
bildung einer neuen regierung
gescheitert und hat den auftrag zur
regierungsbildung zurückgegeben er habe
es nach der parlamentswahl ende
september nicht geschafft seinen rivalen
ganz an den verhandlungstisch zu bringen
nun will präsident den wahlsieger ganz
mit der regierungsbildung beauftragen
angesichts der anhaltenden unruhen hat
die regierung in chile den
ausnahmezustand auf mehr als die hälfte
des landes ausgeweitet
präsident pinera spricht von einem krieg
bei den gewaltsamen protesten gegen die
zunehmende kluft zwischen arm und reich
in chile sind bislang elf menschen ums
leben
zahlreiche supermärkte und tankstellen
wurden geplündert und in brand gesetzt
auslöser der proteste war eine
fahrpreiserhöhung im öffentlichen
nahverkehr die aber bereits
zurückgenommen wurde
in sachsen haben cdu grüne und spd
sieben wochen nach der landtagswahl ihre
koalitionsverhandlungen aufgenommen
ziel sei es bis ende november eine
stabile regierung für die kommenden fünf
jahre zu bilden sagte cdu
ministerpräsident kretschmann als ein
streitpunkt gilt die energie und
kohlepolitik einig ist man sich über den
ausbau des öffentlichen nahverkehrs und
eine personalaufstockung bei der polizei
kurz vor der landtagswahl in thüringen
gibt es dort immer wieder morddrohungen
gegen landespolitiker auch der
spitzenkandidat der grünen dirk adams
ist offenbar von rechtsextremisten
bedroht worden
der grünen-fraktionschef erklärte per e
mail habe ihm der absender eine
sogenannte cyber reichswehr mit gewalt
gedroht sollte er nicht bei den grünen
austreten
auch der cdu-spitzenkandidat mohring
sowie ministerpräsidenten ramelow von
der linken sind wiederholt drohungen
ausgesetzt
in allen fällen ermittelt das
landeskriminalamt
es ist eine schwierige schon auf den
ersten blick verdächtige sache wenn in
einer demokratie eine wahl rückgängig
gemacht wird
sogar dann wenn der weg dazu rechtens
ist da muss man trotzdem genauer
hinschauen morgen auf altenstadt
waldsiedlung in der wetterau in hessen
dort wurde im september ein
ortsvorsteher gewählt der erste bürger
seines dorfes ein mann der npd einer
rechtsextremen verfassungsfeindlichen
partei die nach dem letzten urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts nur deshalb
nicht verboten wird weil sie zu
unbedeutend sei das stimmt wohl im
großen und ganzen die npd hat in hessen
zuletzt 0,2 prozent der stimmen geholt
aber in der wetterau auch in
westdeutschland also gibt es flecken wo
sie auf zehn prozent kommt
und jetzt einen ortsvorsteher stellt
woher kommt das erkundigungen unserer
reporterin isabel de la vega in der
wetterau wo der ortsvorsteher aus der
npd morgen wohl abgewählt wird
sanfte hügel eine schöne landschaft die
wette auf wirkt idyllisch rund um städte
die büdingen leben viele von der
landwirtschaft die npd gute hier bei den
letzten kommunalwahlen mehr als zehn
prozent wie auch in altenstadt hier
sitzt der spd spitzenmann stefan jagsch
seit 2016 in der gemeindevertretung
ergibt sich bodenständig bürgerlich doch
die npd ist eine rechtsextreme partei
sie wird vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet und so hat auch ja kein
anderes radikales gesicht migration
tötet ist dann seine botschaft
deutschland den deutschen
jaxx gehört zu den führenden köpfen der
npd war in hessen sogar landeschefs
diese akteure sind ja nicht zufällig
hier sondern bewusst strategisch
ausgelegt also sprich sie wissen dass im
wetteraukreis beim teil der bevölkerung
oft starken zuspruch stoßen dass er auf
tradierte extrem rechte einstellungen
stoßen diese revolution eher
konservative tradition reicht zurück bis
in die zwanziger jahre damals litten die
wetterauer bauern unter hohen steuern
und einem globalen preisverfall für
agrarprodukte viele verarmten und
mussten ihre höfe zwangsversteigern die
wut auf die sogenannten bonzen der
weimarer republik war groß die nazis
profitierten davon gewannen bei den
wahlen 1932 in manchen orten über 90
prozent der stimmen
die wetterau wurde zu einer nazi
hochburg die es an die iss sind die
dörfer eingerückt und hatte
zwangsversteigerungen verhindert und das
kam natürlich bei den oberhessischen
bauerngut anja dass man da sozusagen
jemanden hatte der 1 gegen den bösen
staat zur seite stand wirtschaftlich
geht es der wetterau auch heute gut die
landwirte bekommen hohe subventionen
dennoch ist der blick nach berlin
kritisch und die afg profitiert auch von
der wut
vielen umweltvorschriften das wird immer
mehr und die bevölkerung zum teil gerade
aus den städten die haben ja gar keine
ahnung wie landwirtschaft betrieben wird
aber trotzdem ist der druck immer größer
auf die landwirtschaft im nahen kefenrod
stimmten bei den landtagswahlen im
vergangenen jahr über 18 prozent zu die
fdp flüchtlinge sind ein weiteres
reizthema
sie würden angeblich besser behandelt
als manche einheimische so das vorurteil
des krieges baden drin auch viel mit
grad welche die jetzt keinen job haben
und wegen jeden cent zum arbeitsamt
rennen müssen nun nachfragen müssen
könnte habt und andere es wirklich ein
aspekt kriegen es geldern gegen diesen
vorwurf müssen sich die lokalpolitiker
von cdu und spd wären sie geben zu dass
ihnen dabei die unterstützung und der
nachwuchs aus den eigenen reihen fehlen
überall dort wo wir verwurzelt sind
stark sind in die vereine gehen
stimmen auch die wahlergebnisse fdp und
npd werden dort stark wo demokratische
parteien platz lassen die
jugendorganisationen der afg letztes
jahr in büdingen die rechte partei weiß
die schwächen der anderen zu nutzen
wir müssen vor allen dingen dort unsere
schwerpunkte setzen wo die etablierte
politik nicht hinreichend agiert und das
ist eben auf dem land der fall und so
ist die beta ein strategischer faktor
für rechte parteien noch einmal gundula
mit nachricht
im bislang grössten rechtsstreit um die
folgen der sucht nach schmerzmitteln
haben in den usa mehrere pharmakonzerne
überraschend einen vergleich erzielt und
so einen prozess in letzter minute
abgewendet wie ein kläger anwalt im us
bundesstaat ohio mitteilte zahlen vier
unternehmen insgesamt 260 millionen
dollar an geschädigte und hinterbliebene
den pharmakonzernen wird vorgeworfen die
risiken süchtig machen dass
schmerzmitteln sogenannten opioiden
verharmlost zu haben
seit ende der 90er jahre sind in den usa
fast 400.000 menschen an den folgen von
opel bis brauch gestorben
die sächsische landeskirche hat das
rücktrittsangebot ihres landesbischofs
karsten renz in angenommen hintergrund
sind vor 30 jahren veröffentlichte texte
des als streng konservativ geltenden
evangelischen theologen die in teilen
als nationalistisch und
demokratiefeindlich eingestuft wurden
die kirchenleitung will sich nun mit der
frage auseinandersetzen was rechtsextrem
sei und was ein wertkonservativer christ
das museum of modern art in new york
gehört zu den renommiertesten
kunstmuseen der welt und ist eine der
touristenattraktionen der stadt nach
vier monaten umbau hat es seit heute
wieder geöffnet und ist größer und
schöner als zuvor auf 3700 zusätzlichen
quadratmetern ausstellungsfläche hat
sich das weltberühmte museum auch
zugleich neu erfunden
so sind neben gemälden deutlich mehr
skulpturen fotografie film und
performance kunst zu sehen
gekostet hat der umbau rund 400
millionen dollar apropos museum
wenn es nur um schöne menschen in
schönen teuren kleidern gehen würde
hätte barbara lueg mit ihrem
kulturbericht aus dem schönen münchen
kaum eine chance gehabt wir sind hier
schließlich im heute journal
aber sie hat uns davon überzeugt dass es
um mehr geht um wertvorstellungen und
den geist der zeit oder so ähnlich und
in solchen notfällen zeigen wir ihnen
sogar schöne menschen in schönen
kleidern
voila das ist en vogue wie man so sagt
sie ist kosmos für stil ikonen und
pompöse sehnsüchte spiegel einer
knallharten glitzerwelt
wie hoch war und ist für viele die bibel
für das was uns ständig umgeht wurde ist
nicht einfach nur hülle sondern mode ist
viel emotionen
sie lassen nichts dichte an sich ran wir
alle brauchen sie weil wir uns alle
kleiden und meistens ist das hässliche
outfit genauso teuer wie der schöne
outfit was schön ist oder hilft oder
angesagt die vogue mischt immer ganz
vorn mit sie setzt trends und maßstäbe
anna wintour die legendäre vogue chefin
der amerikanischen ausgabe wurde über
jahrzehnte zur mächtigsten frau der mode
welt gefürchtet und verehrt berüchtigt
als eiskönigin in der ersten reihe
die ausstellung zeigt die vogue als mode
bibel und plattform für kunst und
fotografie
[Musik]
wo endet mode wo beginnt die kunst und
wie verschmelzen sie mode und kunst
haben sich schon immer getroffen
künstler die mode gestalten modedesigner
die künstlerische arbeiten also ich
glaube das sind kategorien die im grunde
genommen fließend sind wie hier einer
der letzten tour entwürfe karl
lagerfelds fotograf und modedesigner das
legendäre bild der supermodels von
starfotograf lindberg zeitlos schön
auf dem cover der vogue zu landen war
und ist für sie alle ein ritterschlag
die mode triebkraft und irgendwie auch
immer lebenselexier
[Musik]
es ist nun mal ein wunderbares spiel
dass erwachsene frauen mögen wir wollen
eben elegant und anspruchsvoll sein
es ist diese spielerische art mit der
wir uns gut und erwachsen fühlen
doch 40 jahre deutsche vogue zeigt dass
mode immer auch politisch war ein
gesellschaftliches instrument wer lebt
gegen trends wer protestiert
wer will dazugehören und wer wagt sich
weiter vor
wer sich kleidet zeigt sich eben
wenn sie sehen wie mode menschen
verändern kann selbst die ober profis
die das jeden tag machen tragen ein
besonderes outfit und sie verändern sich
der gang verändert sich und das ist
diese macht die ich der mode zu zu
sprechen und die stellen sich junge
modedesigner heute so vor
das könnt ihr das kleid der zukunft sein
größer wenn ich sagen ich wünsche einen
schönen abend wir tun das
[Musik]
knabe liebe zuschauer jetzt wird der
herbst wieder sonnig und neblig bei uns
gibt kein regen mehr und es bleibt sehr
mild temperaturen in mitteleuropa 15 zum
teil bis zu 20 grad noch wärmer über
osteuropa der balkan 20 bis 25 genauso
wie am mittelmeer aber am westlichen
mittelmeer ist es deutlich kühler
vor allem im osten von spanien zum teil
nur zehn grad und das liegt an regen ab
heute nacht dauerregen dort und vor
allen dingen auch auf den balearen wie
mallorca oder ibiza und das bedeutet
unwetterartigen regen bei uns dagegen
sorgt dieses hoch dafür
es bleibt überwiegend trocken nur heute
nacht nicht da haben wir auch den
leichten regen so vom schwarzwald bis
zum einen der in den nächsten stunden
bis morgen früh danach lässt sonst gibt
es ein paar nebelfelder in den
flussniederungen und im nordwesten an
der nordsee bleibt es bewölkt da haben
wir dann morgen im nordwesten ein paar
schauer aber das wird ganz wenig sein
dazu wird dieser frische west bis
südwestwind nach osten hin mecklenburg
brandenburg und so weiter da wird es
dann recht freundlich mit sonne und das
ist auch in der mitte und im süden so
trockenes freundliches wetter nur ebenso
an der donau am main am bodensee
oberrhein da halten sich zum teil bis
zum nachmittag die dichte nebelfelder
und es wird auch nur ein ganz schwacher
nordostwind bei den temperaturen ändert
sich wenig im osten und süden wird es am
wärmsten meist zwischen 17 und 20 grad
im süden bis zu 19
und hier im nordwesten sind es 14 bis 16
grad die aussichten ja es wird auf jeden
fall trocken bleiben auch vielfach
sonnig aber auch die nebelfelder halten
sich häufig und mild ist es außerdem
dazu ich wünschen noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut